good morning my name is Julie
alessandrini I work as a consultant for
work from research especially in the
area of color and image processing and
I'm gonna talk about these two topics
during this conference I have a first
talk about image recognition and a
second talk mainly about color
processing and what you can do with
colors in Mathematica I'll start
explaining very very briefly what the
main point of image I've main workflow
in image recognition is and I'll try to
move right away to some application
examples so you will be all able to see
how to implement implement this in Crete
matter so image recognition what is
immigration p recognition is a really
really broad term that encompasses like
many many different things it is it
intersects with computer vision it
intersects with with machine learning as
ant initial this morning of course it
uses element if you apply the two images
uses element of image filtering
segmentation morphology like it's
basically really really broke so I
wanted to focus on some like the really
key point that are essential to like any
image recognition task first point is
setting goals so I mean you could ask
really really broad questions or really
specific question the important thing is
that your question is clear to you
otherwise it's really very varied it
sounds stupid but it's really important
that the question is is for like crafted
correctly in order to implement an
efficient argument so you could you
could ask for a sample here for some
specific properties for example here I'm
just importing the image and I want to
identify lines because I whatever my
application is I just scared about well
the line lines and some images are or I
could I could as other other question
for example what's the what's the
position of a specific object and so oh
just to show you before I call an
internal function which is basically
image lines so you can achieve these
like few lines of codes
and another question you could ask is
that oh what's the position of things
for example I want to track an object
this is this resemble dedicating in this
fairy will so how can i do that this is
not a line but I have other other ways
to track it down here I'm calling for
example image saliency filter the image
sorry see filter has some certain
measles inside and so you can identify
in this case for example the most
salient point based on colors and
segment it out so here I'm alighting the
salient region while fading away all the
rest of the image and so like here of
course I can can use this to track down
things if I need a there are all sort of
applications and of course you can even
go to to broader questions for example I
could ask what what's the subject I mean
what's represented in this image and and
this is why we started developing image
identify that was shown already this
morning so I I once spent too much time
limit identify and basically so here you
you can just call it this is the cool
with no parameters and we'll just tell
you like the best guessed right away for
what this image is a representation of
in this dog I I populists chose not to
deal with image identify because that's
kind of all under the hood when we are
working to take all the framework out of
the hood and make it available for the
end user but we are not there yet so I
don't know I always have the feeling
that the audience will feel a bit
cheated if I show stuff that you cannot
really control very well yourself so in
my talk i'll try to present application
that you can actually prepare and write
and use in their entirety yourselves so
okay go so I mean gose is the question
and then that's like the like where I'm
going and there's how i'm going there
and this is about features so like if
you if you think about images there are
just a bunch of pixels so in the end
like the for example
average an average image could be
something like this this is a lot of
information but it's also mainly useless
so how can I deal with this information
overload in Anthony and other people
show like before that you can do
dimensionality reduction you can do like
feature in more in general I would talk
about feature extraction here the point
is once I have my question not
everything in the image is relevant as
answer to that question so another
extremely important point is which
features which are in like more physical
term the observables that are relevant
to my to my problem to my motor or
whatever so of course you can do this in
Mathematica as well it depends on
basically on in which which feature your
interest at the end you will use
different approaches so for example
sometimes you can just use simple
filtering this is a color image of the
dog and like this is a stupid thing but
it's really important sorry I have to
import the image first is interred
working yes great so this is something
stupid but many time over looked like
many many many many occasion I don't
really need color information in as
human being identified a lot of things
without colors just using the luminosity
of the the intensity information so you
can use simple filtering like this this
is stupid example but you can use more
sophisticated filtering to treat your
images or you can actually do
segmentation for example here I have
this image of a soccer field so what one
thing you can do let's say I'm
interested in in finding like corners
here and like by mixing filtering and
segmentation I can use this in recent
function local attack pipeline rise that
you locally binarize image with a local
threshold and again here for example
music gray scale because for getting
corners is not really important where
green or white is and and here so I can
get like the most salient bit intermol
corners of the image we let again four
lines of course
and then you can use image recognition
itself to take out features for you in
order to perform another image
recognition task for example here i'm
importing a face database let's see like
something like this and like these are
big images I mean big there's a lot of
extra information which is not strictly
speaking related to faces so I can call
in like computer vision function which
is like fine faces for example and and
this will allow me to extract a more
proper data oops sorry so here for
example is a mapping between the the
original image and something which is
more more proper for an image
recognition task and this was also
extremely easy just basically cropping
with fine places and a bit of I guess
I'm equalizing the images yes I'm
calling image transform this is an old
simple pre-processing step that can like
in greatly improve the accuracy of of
your classification recognition
detection functions so all this stuff
can be done and last last bit but not
not less important is the training so
we've seen this example already like how
to identify digits here I took the
liberty of greatly trimming the the
training set so here I have for each
digit I have just two images and and
this is an example of how you like the
training set is important so like here I
have a digit for this I manually draw
and this is not recognized but let's I
mean this may be a failure of the
argument but in this case much more
likely that is a failure of my failures
in myself my training set is not good
enough so like doing something as stupid
as like increasing a bit the size of the
training set allows me to to recognize
the stitches correctly so last step not
less important like be
sure about the quality of a training set
actually this is this part it was also
really important when we trained in
magenta Phi at the beginning it was a
lot of noise in the training set because
we didn't start with like our personal
training set we start collecting images
from all over the place and and there
are all sorts of problems because of
this because i remember was for example
want one concept look we wanted to
identify was like airplane seats and
turn out that like the image net since
that the library data set for for
airplane seat what was full of pictures
of men like human being seated on an
airplane seat so basically because I
people were uploading those images by it
was like crowd from the project so in
the end when we started trying image and
different people that we were seeing
results as airplane seats and why why
this is an apron see okay it's really
easy to understand when you go and check
manually in the trainings that you see
that actually you have you have
basically wrong in wrong creation so
this part can be difficult to automate
in a sense that human judgment is still
really really important but under
underlines greatly the importance of
like a good having a curated proper
training set and this is most I think
this is all what I'm going to say about
like the theoretical introduction also
because the time is not so much so I I'd
like to move right away to three
application examples hoping to enough
time to go through all of them so the
first one is a skin detector it's really
simple like few lying game few lines of
code project so the purpose of this is
let's start from a picture of the of a
manual one whatever and we would like to
be able to go to this point here so we
have basically a heat map or a binary
map whatever that tells me where this
skin of this person is and this may have
like all sort of application i was
talking somebody this morning that
there's an app apparently on the phone
that you can take picture with your skin
and send it to a doctor to have like a
straight away a little knowledge about
your like physiological conditions and
to do this if use a picture of yourself
or like your baby's whichever you want
to be able to extract again this is a
feature that you want to extract maybe
for faster processing maybe we're happy
with this i mean this this is just a
step I mean it's up to us to decide how
to use it but still this is again I
don't need the whole thing I just need
like the skin so it may be useful to get
out so how do we do this in Mathematica
okay first we need a face data set and
and i'm using a head i would put the
link in the in the presentation so you
can try this on your own now i'm just
loading this locally this is much faster
so I'm loading basically in the
classification what pixels in images are
skin and what pixel images are not skin
and just to see basically what's
happening this is the chromaticity plot
oh but by the way I'm talking about
colors tomorrow the what's written on
the program is slightly wrong so if you
are a bit interested in understanding
why colors are important you can come to
my talk tomorrow so this here is the
distribution of a skin pixel this one
and then own skin pixel and you see that
they have that basically they're quite
skin pics are quite a compact region in
the 3d LED space more on the leb space
tomorrow so we can actually try to a
hope to create a good classifier i'm
using here nice bias because it's quite
fast and i want to apply to every pixel
of images i sent me say you can always
force classified user specific method
and then we can see how accurate will be
ok this is pre evaluator so it's quite
good in getting the right answer on the
training set and and we can also like
visually see who's take a while probably
to plot with the density in 3d but just
do to see a bit better what's going on
within classify this don't be i mean the
region here is pretty bad because i'm
using that knife bias are the method
will create a more
a more compact region here but as I say
I want I want a fast classifier and the
performance not not much worse so now
but I have my classifier i can actually
usually what you do you divide your your
your training set like in one part de
jesus used strictly for training and one
part which is for testing so here like
this part was never seen by the
classifier and I'm using it to test the
image so i have also fairly good
prediction power on pixels that are not
in my training set this is the confusion
matrix so like when I'm under y agua now
the prediction was good and these are
the across the eigen are ardent
misaligned prediction and and now that
everything is ready I can define a
function which basically will take will
perform all this operation extract the
color from the image take out the image
data send them to the classifier
function and then put it back with our a
leash shape in like in a good shape for
like being represented as an image if I
wondering what this is this is a new
operator and is I think right
composition and it's quite useful to
write function in the way you think
about them and not in the way
Mathematica will apply them so like this
is actually the last three C's the first
function applied and this is the last
function applied and you can read
through this is quite easy to comment
and explain to people so just some bit
of programming here let's let's try this
so this is I just pick random random
faces from the database so this for
example I chose because with interesting
because it has some problems as like we
have been a bit naive and that there are
also other natural colors that can be
close to skin colors for example this
woman has like hair that are close to
dark skin in term of colors by like if I
go with darker hair this was the image
ahead in the example this is like fairly
accurate depiction of the of the skin
pixels I mean this class if I tend to be
more the give more false positive and
false negative and then it depends on
how you train it and what's your purpose
if you want more disordered you can
again find the image which can
confused classify this one has also some
natural colors in the in the clothes but
it depends again on the image and for
example this one here it's fairly good
and you can make it even better with
them I mean we talked about
pre-processing but there's also post
processing so after you have run your
classifier like again I'm doing here
like a bit of morphological operation
like I'm opening the opening basically
reduced small white features in the in
the image i'm so i'm using opening on
the image with the disc matrix to
basically close this white part and by
analyzing the image and deleting the
small binary component and and you see
that just by one line of code i can
clean up fairly well the resulting
segmentation so again like this was like
phew line of code is quite fast and i
still get something of course i can i
can do i can do much more if I'm would
if i take more time again this is a
quick one but fairly accurate one
classifier i'll try i'll try to
distinguish female from man or or like
men from women whatever so again i'm
loading a data set of tagged images and
and these images are all in the form
like i have a picture and this female
have a picture and his men and all like
listening it's again fairly fairly
simple thing and once I have it I i use
physical devices like the feature
example instruction I thought I I show
before I'm I'm calling fine faces and
Instagram transform to have like uniform
faces like this yeah so yeah mostly I
mean this or our misaligned but so I
cannot fix for everything I do as much
as I can move like little little steps
and then we train the classifier again
the accuracy is fairly good on the on
the training set not so good as just
eighty-five percent on the test set but
equal is performing quite 12 on on real
images and this is something that you
can do easily mathematical once you have
you have your classifier function you
can again in few lines of code you can
park this into like I'm writing this
gendered attack function and in like
this performs like it is a bit closer to
like in
that one line example I want to show
this because I you can really easily
build your interface this is just
checking if there's a face is there's no
face you can you can write all kind of
exit scenario and it's still really
really a brief and concise in term of
code so once once you have your your
function just these bunch of images i
took from google or pixabay i don't like
public domain images of people and you
you compute the result and then you can
quickly create a report this is
something you can you can deploy this to
the cloud you can you can do whatever
you like with this it's really few lines
and doesn't take much time so like it
doesn't look like every time like for
example this is a fine faces problem so
this this face was not recognized by
fine faces but when when in the face is
picked actually this is not so bad so
this was like okay I could I could be
lying but please believe me these are
the first images I I could find of like
for like close close view and time of
faces and and again this is a fairly
decent data set but not huge I think I
have hundred images of men and hundred
feet of a women so it's not something
that you require you ears to to assemble
and and if we want to do something a bit
more complicated how much time do I have
I don't know let's say five minutes
here's a like instead of a binary
classifier I'm i have four categories so
let's see if I can remind my purpose
here let's see if I can classify images
of seasons based on the content and as
I'm mailing dealing with color
processing I will use again colors to do
this oops sorry so what I do here is I
got like hundred or so yes images of
seasons from from google google images
and so just to see what they are there's
something like this so this is will just
I write spring summer winter and
negative images so they may be relevant
there may be irrelevant I'm not curating
this this set and once I I do this I go
and see what's the color distribution so
this is much smaller than sorry all four
of them fit on my screen but what's the
other one here yeah okay let's see okay
you don't mind let's be between with
winter we don't have winter so spring
summer you see that the coral
distribution is like not not
encompassing with full RGB square it's
still a reasonable chunk but let's hope
the overlap is not too much and see what
we can do with this so there's I'll try
to go through this in steps like in
terms of increasing complexity so we can
see what we get from different
approaches like first approach like the
super naive one we can throw images
within classify so we can see what
classifier is able to do just with the
image set and yeah I can do in five
minutes so this is again our usual
friend classifier function I've again
divided the training slavia there my
whole data set in training site and test
set just to see what's going on and if
we see here i will change every time
slightly because I'm randomizing
training saturn and test says so this is
why i changed so i have like seventy two
percent which is not great accuracy
considering that this is a training set
but again i was doing no basically no
pre-processing so it's not not too bad
clock classified and but this is fairly
low sixty-two percent on the test set so
okay this was a bit stupid let's let's
try to put some to inject some human
intelligence in this computation so one
thing i can do is to go again to the LED
color space why i do this i mean again
more about this tomorrow but what I can
do here is basically reduce the
dimensionality of the problem from a 3d
problem to a 2d problem because i'm
actually dealing with color so with
Hughes I don't really care about the
brightness of those pixels so let let's
go to the LA big color space and let's
see how the season will look here so
this is like the view from the top I'll
try to go through this quickly and
instead of using the full images i'm
dressed instructing the dominant colors
on the image so I
greatly simplifying the problem so this
is an example of what I get so like
random media means images i'm getting a
difference at the color every time i'm
using four colors for each image so i
define a function that extracts the
dominant color and then I try with for
example here up sorry at four color
classifier and this is doing like
already better before we were on like 16
or 70 something and actually we see but
simplifying the problem simply find the
feature space we can actually get a
better result because if all the extra
information was noise it wasn't really
needed it was just annoying the
classifier actually and but still is not
doing much much better on the on the
test set I can try with more colors here
I have six colors and I have to redefine
this and retrain and I get even get even
slightly better here but still this is
also a bit better but but I'm not close
to what i really call a good good
classifier so let's try different
approaches so another approach i have
and i won't show this because i'm
running out of time is let's use a
probability distribution and my first
support was a bit naive was like let's
use a flat distribution so we use region
framework and defined region distance as
like quality measure in order to to see
what's going on and so they basically
this is a 2d region defined by the
distribution of colors this is doing
better but so quite here I was defining
some function you can read about this in
the in the notebook I don't want to take
too much time time for example like this
is example of how you define your custom
classified it's not calling classify
your writing this on your own and then
you put the picture in and you choose
the number of colors you want to extract
on the image and it will give you an
answer so it's doing very well with
winter and autumn but then we can see in
the next page but if we do the proper
set it's even actually worse on average
and why so this is because like if we
miss the train excitement by the way and
if we if we look at the single real
seasons we see
spring and summer there were really
close in term of regions of the habla
was really huge and so this approach is
doing is doing a quick better on old
autumn and winter but is not really good
here so what I can do is go a step
farther and compute the proper
distribution instead of staying with
just just a flat distribution so this
one here is the amusing smooth current
distribution to smooth a bit this
discrete distribution of colors and this
is the proper college distribution for
my my training set and okay this from
from the top so this is just the white
thing is just I wasn't taking enough
time to fix the ant analyzing of their
of a graph but it's not really important
the important thing is now i owe this is
my only formula by the way I'm done I'm
done and so I will define a new season
classifier that is using this full
probability distribution and when once i
have it i can finally put it to a test
and we can see oh i haven't defined
everything sorry let me oh yeah i have
to do this first you
now that I had this whoo why it was
working the moment ago as usual yeah
apparently still working here okay so
that was the only one not working I can
I mean you see that the quality is
really really improved so I'm here like
by using i injected a bit more
information in term of distribution not
so much slightly more complex but i have
a function that gives me like huge
amount of improvement over the last over
the result and we can see like this is a
kind of a final showcase I can take
random images and sometimes have
misclassified images but a very very
very understandable with some more like
autumn colors but like it is performing
fairly fairly well in in terms of like
good and bad classification so basically
this is it sorry I Russia bit the last
the last part but yes okay I'm done
thank you for your attention